I
most people they look at me they don't
think i have a disability because i
don't i really don't have the physical
appearance of someone who has a
disability and i'm able to conceal my
certain aspects of my disability more so
there are people with my condition
but i want people understand about
autism is that where we're human beings
to we want to be treated with respect we
want to be understood having autism does
does affect my ability to maintain and
and build relationships I've made some
good friends but seems like a lot of
them I've I've end up alienating myself
from because of my my behavioral issues
I wasn't even aware of of my behavior
and I wasn't I wasn't um and I had no
idea that the reason why I behaved is it
so radically was because I had autism
there's not too many support systems for
people with autism I mean there are for
children but this there's not too many
out there for adults
I think it's great that that there's
research being done to help people
adults with autism because it means
people like me are going to get more
help in the future
I said not one have any friends at all
because I was just terrified of of
making friends and being in in social
settings and I want no part of it what's
fulfilling about having friends and fam
members is that I yet I have people who
were understanding and and and care
enough about me to put up with my
misgivings my flaws and love me no
matter what